you do love scary movies sorry I was
just looking around it's just kind of a
little thing I don't always watch them
yeah I do but there's a lot there's a
lot of them yeah it's either
documentaries what's your favorite scary
movie I'm calling them scary movies I
mean probably I always say The Shining
it just it's just directed like
everything that moves it's just that
they don't make them like that anymore
no but there's a lot of good ones if you
ever do you watch them sometimes it's
the only ones like I can stay awake for
at night okay well I have some that are
quality that I can give you a list that
you can avoid all the that's out
there that Gets applauded By Rotten
Tomatoes which I have a thing for yeah
everything's 99 well yeah are they
getting paid I mean how could you say
this is so good when you watch it
and you're like yeah that was like a 63.
oh so you don't agree with rotten I do
not agree with Rotten Tomatoes I think
they get changed I think that somebody
pays them I think the Studios have deals
oh there's something there's something
wrong I can see that yeah